beyond the imagination beyond the
understanding of time beyond all thought
that man has ever conjured up there is
the mysterious realm of the plotter as
you can see this purgatory hell said
quite an impact on me
I had bathed and cut my hair I have even
shaped this horrifying realm and when we
do so much to a man for massive insane
who can appreciate the sacrifice I need
your red cherry cupcake vodka sir Thank
You Carl
okay so the plot hole is not that bad
I dare even argue its kind of pleasant
as a cable TV HBO king-size bed the
sofas a bit tacky but what are you gonna
do and I also know that a lot of you
seem to think that I was a mop that went
in the plot hole that was just a phase
doesn't everybody go through that just
me okay
well bottom line I'm here and it's
pretty tough to do reviews when you're a
plot hole especially your memory I do
find I get certain things backwards
sometimes but when you get down to it I
am still the essential same person I
always was and I still have a good
recollection of all my favorite people
such as like Cara Todd stinky dopey doc
so it's pretty much intact however I
have come across someone who has tried
to do something very similar to what I
have tried to do an internet celebrity
reviewing things for a mere four to five
years what a loser
well I am here to expose this fraud for
the fraud that he is that's right I am
here to talk about his cinematic lack of
an opus kick-ass II
you
written directed and starring some guy
Colvin nostalgic cricket he comes up
with an ingenious plan
he was an idea take a ton of Internet
critics that do nothing but make fun of
movies and have them make a movie
everyone else can make fun of yeah I
can't see this backfiring at all
is it an embarrassment oh you have no
idea so let's see the fruit of the
Internet's poorly put together loins
this is kickassia so we get a quick
history and a little speck of land
called Molossia it is run by a man named
Kevin ball but through a strange
loophole it is technically considered a
nation you know this openings looking a
little familiar I know
so this douche samwich called the
nostalgia cricket comes along and says
he wants to take over Boz acre of land
why because two acres would have been
out of their budget he calls up all his
fellow reviewers in a bit that probably
goes on too long uh yeah what does its
time mean you know the way I can feel us
at the takeover of Molossia
hey yeah what's this it's time thing
you're talking about don't you know now
and comedy ensues next he gets them all
in a hotel room where he explains his
plan but it's only an acre of land what
can we do with an acre of land you know
there's another group of people that
thought like you linked our and they
were called Nazis are you a Nazi Letarte
ha ha what a Nazis around now I'm not a
Nazi now let me tell you about a group
of people that didn't give up they were
called Nazis hey look it's that joke
everybody thought would destroy the
Internet but now nobody gives a shit
about so what are you people
a Nazi or not say shit
yes let it be known that Nazis are not
funny
despite the fact that they make Jewish
comedians rich when a dick ton of awards
and make what's considered one of the
greatest film comedies and loudly
musicals of all time
but aside from that shame so they attack
Kevin Baugh who has clearly too good at
sense of humor but he's able to defend
himself by oh gee I don't know defending
himself so they try again but this time
they start loading up get your mp5
Linkara get your magic gun pens I start
wrapping bury and explosives but not
before this bit of confusing this you
know Spoony you would really help the
team out if you were do well you know
some of them it would just be this once
boonie just this once and you can go
back to normal and maybe then I can stop
doing my Batman impression
well a mortal there's no normal I don't
even know what normal is sometimes we
all need to give in to the madness
yeah he's off to go get your Razzie
award all right so the next morning they
get dressed up in their battle gear and
they let loose on velocity
look out he has a demo version of After
Effects but unfortunately Kevin Baugh
has wooden cannon correction a wooden
candidate fires pixelated energy balls
from Mega Man but the team breaks
through which leads to the only
convincing relationship in the entire
movie this is it Barry at least you're
dying for a good cause either whether
they're there to serve you body
yes it's sad to see a Frenchman part
with a bear he said a few minutes ago
he'd gladly sacrifice ow
but we see that Kevin Baugh has in fact
upgraded from After Effects to Photoshop
style lens flares this unexpected effect
apparently is so threatening that it's
scare fail is to hide behind the shed
and then awkwardly enough disappear in
the next shot
maybe Canadians are just really fast
runners this leads to Lee the guy who's
always in a still picture finally
turning three-dimensions don't get me
angry you wouldn't like me when I'm
angry
yes Bruce Banner Way says that line
always turns into a giant green monster
of death when this guy Kim now movies
are fading enough I guess
Lee actually has the strength of the
Hulk now too as he beats the shit out of
bond forces him to retreat he puts on
disguise that doesn't really fool them
but he says they won so they don't care
and the new government is formed in the
renamed nation of kickassia my friends
this is indeed a great day let's
celebrate by putting our arms around
nostalgia chick taking them off and then
putting them back on in the next shot
just to take them off again in a scene
that anyone with an attention span would
say goes on forever we see what all the
new members of kickassia do and i mean
all of them around guys Smurf hair
Puerto Rican Carleton Pepe LePew
and an obnoxious political knockoff well
he is a maverick to say the least though
no matter what his decision
theme whatever we disagree on I still
stand right by him yes we've all seen
the impressions we've all made fun of
her before but I'm sorry it's not fair
Michelle Obama is a lovely lady she gets
no credit but no self indulgent right
would be complete without the Papa Bear
of self-indulgence right the nostalgia
cricket mr. critic would you say your
diabolical plan is to take over the wild
not surely well then would you say your
plan is to one day conquer the galaxy
even surely say critic do you get a lot
of pussy with that outfit of course
thank you still not letting that meme
die huh don't worry in a few years I'm
sure this will go the rather the numa
numa kid in the dramatic Gover don't
remember those videos my point exactly
but it turns out most of his time is
spent just sitting around watching
Hogan's Heroes probably trying to figure
out how they can make lame nasty jokes
back then without people going apeshit
Oh on favor say aye aye motion passes go
away but a conveniently forced plot
three taps them on the foot and it
appears to be a receipt for 20 tons of
dynamite ordered by cool the nostalgia
critic oh wait why is that big deal
wasn't Molossia covered in explosives
before anyway could he just be boosting
up security even more you know like it
real cannons instead of wooden ones
doesn't this actually make pure logical
sense actually in this movie that isn't
reason to panic Joe tries to tell cinema
snob about what they found as we see the
Vice President it's not all she sees how
about I make you some tea there mr.
president
well yes mrs. vice president Debbie
wonderful whoa is that just a term or
was there an off-screen wedding ceremony
we missed I've heard of Vegas weddings
but we know weddings the poison doesn't
work thanks to the power stupidity but
that just allows the rest of the team to
plot their own way of axing him off a
whole lot of shit is going down
snob fortunately cinema snob seems to be
on the cricket side so he delicately
breaks the news everybody thinks you're
nuts about a subtle is a guy who reviews
porn would be but he quickly finds out
that crazy plans are often led by crazy
people
discover that the world is filled with
nasty Westies and a lot of those nasty
Westies want what I got so any of them
trying to take away what I have I'm not
afraid to go down with the ship take
everybody with me
Wow his acting coach Ren Hoek must be so
proud of him he DS not I going crazy
it is I who I'm mad insert another
crowded hotel room scene because lord
knows we haven't seen enough of those
and we see that loyal lucky film brain
has been listening the whole time and
they were talking about killing you and
they were talking about different ways
of killing and the sermon scope was like
it's my plan so I'll kill him so I ran
back here as fast psycho but they saw me
so Superman broken this is the
micromachining I'm gonna tell you also
as evil time with you I'm gonna tell you
about how honest you but you aren't
trying to take you with the try to tell
how you're gonna take without you better
if I think of where it is a Hydra
machine it's not a real thing
so they res snob and kick him out of the
country resulting in what I'm sure is
the only use of vogner will ever see in
any of these anniversary specials made
of harshness on this world
man not since I reached into my pocket
thinking I had a 21 Willy owes just a
gum wrapper have I been so emotionally
moved he goes into his room and finds
that somebody has redesigned it to look
like his old reviewing headquarters and
that someone is and night some on my
team or mati that was due first they
have a competition how many times can
someone say dammit mati versus how many
times can someone do a conehead
impression demon mati it's totally gonna
backfire mati but it webcast
Tim it might eat you are you willing to
let down the people that got you here
Taramati
another ass muncher damn it mati you
can't change in destiny you can only
choose to read it yeah I'm sure that's
the last of the planet sweets I've ever
hearing these specials - so the rest of
the group figures the only way to stop
their fearless leader is to send in
Spoony as doctor and say no oh thank god
we could use some mugging in this movie
give in to the madness Moony deep down
inside you know who you truly are no I
won't be able to
oh jesus is he literally chewing the
scenery I think even the curtains
credited themselves as Alex smithy in
the scene alright
I'll give in to the madness so he goes
through a transformation that makes
Sailor moons look like a minor headache
then we see him turn into the evil
doctor in Santa
and what's this evil genius going to do
well I'm sure he's gonna build some
gigantic bomb or put together some
diabolical poison to destroy him with or
donkey punch him and throw down
Wrestlemania um less insane Oh always
known as a fighter did you get
fisticuffs often well I guessed he must
have because they went throw them in a
hand-to-hand combat just to lose so then
what happens they throw him in a
hand-to-hand combat so we can lose Oh
for god sakes can someone just go beep
beep every single time applying fails
but hey this is a channel awesome
production I throw any pointless cameos
in the future I mean aside from the fact
that this whole thing is a collection of
pointless cameos when you get down to it
Shunta cries well that's one less
running joke we can cross off the
reviewers list wait a minute
it's it Santa Christ made out of the
hopes and dreams of people everywhere I
thought he was made out of the need to
insult several religions at once come on
people let's show what it truly means to
believe so
whatever story we were going with before
has suddenly taken a backseat to ripoff
Peter Pan Care Bears and whatever other
children's story will be ashamed to be
referenced in this we believe in Santa
Christ we believe in Santa Christ we
believe in Santa Christ so they chant
his name over and over and over and just
as you'd whimsically expect it doesn't
do a goddamn thing all of you it
wouldn't work
okay so returning to the plot they
decide to let Linkara take control of
the situation but first he has to put on
his battle attire
okay day this calls for an hour detour
away from the plot just assume that
Northern Europe here is a government
house I thought you needed ice for this
do you I don't know how do you play this
game anyway
no guys glad you asked
you got your deck of 56 risk card free
red dice two white dice six sets of
colour armies and of course your game
board because every board game has a
game board yeah it's good enough thanks
for James well thank you for the
obligatory cameo oh it's okay the NC has
written your coattails enough so they
get their plane together and go out to
the man who never really had a plan you
magnificent bastard I read your book
look you can barely write a screenplay
what chance does a book have
ah they're using the explosions that
always leaves the ground without being
the least bit damaged subtle something
Nick's the old plan of just beating the
shit out of him in favor of a new plan
of just beating the shit out of him mrs.
vice president seriously what was up
with that tries to take the post for
herself but it turns out everyone is
just as greedy as the next well
obviously the only thing that can solve
this is a biblical Second Coming Santa
Gras or an idiot in an offensive costume
on the third day I rise again in
fulfillment of the awesomeness everyone
who saw their killing yeah hey come out
we have enough camera whoring from
Spoony already so Santa Christ convinces
them to give mr. Baugh his land back and
even forces the Nostalgia cricket to
apologize let's make an obscure
reference to the ending of home alone
that nobody will draw a connection to
now if only he was really hurt as bad as
Joe Pesci wasn't that movie so any
lessons learned
no any points made no any reason that
this should have happened at all
no welcome to a complete waste of money
kids you'd probably be better off just
throwing it on a fire so you can inhale
the fumes that would make you
hallucinate something better than this
seriously what can you say about a movie
that I guess is supposed to be about
nothing it's like it's Seinfeld had
cheap explosions in it I don't know if
I'm supposed to laugh or pity the
hour-and-a-half
I just lost but don't worry even bigger
waste of time it's on his way so the
nostalgia crickets reckoning is far from
over